et dimanche 21 février marisol touraine
ministre de la santé a annoncé vouloir
mettre en tablier en application une
augmentation forte et significative du
prix du tabac le plus vite possible elle
s'est même dit favorable à un paquet à
10 euros tout en reconnaissant que ce ne
serait pas sous ce quinquennat
actuellement le prix moyen d'un paquet
de cigarettes est de 7 euros dans les
yvelines les professionnels craignent le
développement grandissant du marché
parallèle écoutez c'est la provocation
c'est pour cacher d'autres mesures qui
n'arrive pas à tenir et que quand on
parle du tabac on parle pas d'autre
chose on n'est pas contre la politique
de santé publique ce qu'on veut c'est
que on n'est pas 25 à 30% de tabac de
contrebande
vendue au noir sous le manteau on veut
que toute la basse normandie chez nous
c'est tout ce qu'on réclame